so disneyland does about 3.8 billion
dollars a year of revenue every day
about 50 000 people come to the park so
you know just roughly speaking they make
about
just over 200 per guest per year
and that's that's not counting the
hotels the flights and the
and a bunch of the auxiliary stuff so a
ticket into the park is like 120 bucks
and then you spend like another 100
bucks on food and merch so what happened
so walt disney basically
his story is kind of amazing so he he
grows up
and he
he's actually from your your hometown i
don't know if you know this you probably
probably do but he's from missouri
and i didn't know that
apparently there's a place in missouri
called electric park have you ever heard
of this no because this is the
inspiration for disneyland when he's
eight years old he goes to this place
called electric park and electric park
was kind of known for two things one it
was it was an amusement park
and the second is it was really clean
and that's like one of the biggest
things about disneyland is disneyland is
really clean so imagine having 50 000
guests over to your house but somehow
everything stays really really clean um
and that was like he's fanatical about
this so he goes to electric park
and he wants to be a cartoonist
he uh ends up working at an ad agency
and then he creates his first business
it's called laphograms and he's
basically doing these like kind of like
animated uh cards but you know a bad
business deal leads it starts working
but then he cuts a bad business deal
where uh he's owed a bunch of money by
one client and then they don't pay him
and the business goes under and so he
says okay
let's go to hollywood and um
and he tells his brother let's go to
hollywood and let's create another
business and so they go
and they create disney brothers cartoon
studio and this is where they create
mickey mouse this is where they create
snow white that's the first big hit so
the company goes from like in debt or
making no money to making millions of
dollars off of snow white that was like
the big win
and so he's like okay this is kind of
working
and
the business is doing all right it's not
going gangbusters
um but it's a float and he's working on
his next story he's working on pinocchio
he's working on a couple other stories
and he's always had this crazy idea
about amusement parks ever since
electric park and he takes his daughter
to the local merry-go-round and he's
like ah this is like so boring like why
isn't there something more grand than
just this merry-go-round like my
daughter loves this but like this is so
boring for the parents and this is just
one ride like what if i made a place
that was um
you know what if i made a place that was
fun for both the parents and the kids to
go to
which is like a similar theme with all
pixar movies and disney disney movies
which is like the movie is enjoyable toy
story is enjoyable to an adult and a kid
it has like two layers to it both can
enjoy a different piece of it
and so he's like
and so what how did they actually come
about this how did they actually like
figure out the idea so they started by
doing research they went to every theme
park they could find
they went to the world's fair they went
to a whole bunch of places getting
inspiration and ideas and mesh and
thinking about what is bad about this
experience what can be made better so
things being dirty blah blah blah
and he's like okay um he starts thinking
about the design of the place and
electric park had this um train that
went around the whole park and so if you
go to disneyland that's still the thing
there's right when you enter there's a
train and the train will take you around
the whole circumference of the park
and he's like all right i'm gonna build
i used to tell people one of these days
i'm gonna build an amusement park and it
is gonna be clean
and he takes two guys off of pinocchio
and he says hey
listen
um i want you guys to start uh start
working on like secret project x
and um he's like you know it's a shame
that when people come to hollywood
there's nothing to see here like people
all around the world have heard of
hollywood they come here there's the
sign where it says hollywood and the
letters on the hill but there's nowhere
to see hollywood so he basically is like
uh guys if anybody came to even see our
animation studio they just see a bunch
of dudes hunched over over drawings it's
not they're not very impressive let's
build something amazing in hollywood and
guys get super excited they start doing
research but then
reality hits they have to they're
working on pinocchio they ought to ship
it they're working on fantasia they got
to ship it then world war ii happens so
all of all of world war ii happens
and then he comes back because he hires
this guy kimball to work in his studio
and kimball's like this junior kind of
animator guy
and
kimball invites all the co-workers over
to his house for like a barbecue or a
birthday party or something like that
and in the back in the backyard of his
house he's like oh by the way you guys
don't know this but my hobby is i build
these little trains almost like the
steamboat style train like it's like a
life-size thing it was very small uh
it's like you know one one uh
like whatever one link of a train
basically you have you cause this guy's
name is ward kimball if you google him
he looks like a cartoon
and you can see his his train too so
walt goes to this thing he's blown away
he's seeing the train
up close and he's like dude ward built
this thing
okay we're the whole mickey he says he
comes back to the office he sends a memo
he says mickey mouse park is back on and
he tells the shareholders shareholders
say
don't do it movie studio is already on
on edge this sounds like a big
distraction it's against the charter of
the company uh we don't want you doing
this he says okay um no problem i
understand
i'll create a new company
so he just creates another company to
create the park he's like i'm still
going to do this but if you don't want
in i'll do this myself
and um and he calls it like a red law or
whatever something like that which is
like you know uh
walter backwards uh is kind of the name
where he names it he starts working on
it and so he's like all right how do i
fund this thing he thinks it's going to
take five million dollars to build
disneyland
and in actuality it ends up taking 17
million dollars to do it and so he's
like all right how do i fund this he uh
he takes his uh his life insurance
policy and he takes a big loan against
that that gives him like you know 100
grand or so to go do this
then he sells a house that he had in
palm springs so that's like the next
seed money that he goes through that
pretty quickly
then he goes all right i need some
bigger money how do i get millions of
dollars for this okay he goes to abc the
tv network and he says hey abc
you're struggling right now you don't
have much tv programming i will create
this this program called like whatever
like the wonderful world of disney or
something like that i'll create a tv
show for you that'll air every sunday
if you invest in my park idea so disney
basically puts down half a million
dollars plus another about six and a
half of loans and bonds and they owned
34 of disneyland and so that's how he
got the next seven million bucks and
then he did the same thing with two
other companies and then he sold some
sponsorships he he like
accumulates together the 17 million
dollars hustled his way he hustled his
way to doing it the other thing that he
did was he was like all right um
you know this this thing works because
um he's like i gotta hi i gotta have
like the uh the rides work automatically
and so he created this thing where if
you go to disneyland now you sit in a
ride and you go and it's sort of like a
it's like a stage play that plays out
but it's all synchronized when your
little like roller coaster cart enters
this room the lights go on the character
makes a sound and then when you leave
the room it all folds back into its
thing and that's called animatronics and
so basically audio animatronics was like
the thing he wanted to do which was like
he wanted live animals but it's too much
work so instead of live animals he
created these robotic animals and he
said i'm going to synchronize the
movements to music on a loop and there's
this one guy who was just working on
only this
and he was kind of in front of a green
screen trying to make this like puppet
do this thing synchronized to music and
eventually they finally figured it out
and that was like the big breakthrough
so okay let me fast forward a little bit
they open the park they build the whole
thing in less than one year
they open the park and he only invited
like 1500 people to it or something like
that uh like invite only launch but
somebody counterfeited the tickets and
so double the number of people showed up
with counterfeit tickets on day one
because double the number of people
showed up uh everything breaks the
plumbing breaks because there's too many
people using water in the park more than
the load was able to handle so he they
come to him they want we got a problem
the plumbing is broken you have to make
a choice toilets are water fountains
he's like toilets for sure and so he
there's no water there's no drinking
water that day the asphalt was still so
freshly poured that like women's high
heels was getting stuck in the cement oh
no because it was like caving in it was
basically a giant disaster and he does
some pr he basically says look
um
we have you know we had to work out the
kinks give me a month and basically give
me give me some time and this thing will
be smooth and sure enough within a month
the the baby is
you know humming and in seven weeks he
does a million visitors so it was kind
of an immediate hit once he did it
because it was such a famous idea it was
disney right off the bat
or at this air at this point how famous
were they they were like i mean they
were a big deal they weren't like
semi-famous they hadn't had like
i mean nowhere near what they are now
but like they were semi-famous really
the abc show
which he was doing while he was building
the park
was almost like the hype video for the
for the park launch was he just grinding
the whole time yeah a crazy amount of
work and so he he creates this thing and
you know it's basically the sixth or
seventh most visited tourist destination
in the world now
and um you know it's kind of this crazy
place i think
which is kind of shocking
i think disney or the theme park
division prior to covid was the most
profitable
part of the company wasn't it except for
well not profitable because it had a lot
of expenses but in terms of gross profit
yes because they had a lot of revenue
and a lot of expenses um but now disney
plus is like the bigger thing because
disney plus is like pure profit business
basically took all that ip that people
loved and created a streaming service
but before that before covey before plus
i like disneyland it wasn't
it wasn't a project it was a
like a major a value creation a lot of
value was created there i wanted to know
is this a is this a loss leader or is
this a um a cash cow and it's it's more
like a cash out it's hard to tell
because every company's like accounting
makes everything look like it's like
losing money you know what i mean like
accounting can make something look
amazing or terrible
regardless of it but you know the parks
division parks and resorts was doing you
know
billions like 30 billion dollars a year
or something crazy like that so it was
you know obviously became a smash
success when he wanted to do disney
world in florida he creates five
stealth companies because he's like
disneyland was a hit he's like i'm
looking for the second location if
anybody finds out where i'm looking the
price will go up so he creates five
shell companies he starts buying up land
in florida sure enough it leaks out the
day after it leaks the price per i think
acre went from like a hundred and eighty
dollars an acre to eighteen thousand
dollars an acre basically
he couldn't buy any more once the news
leaked and uh and you know he had this
like kind of like inspiring vision so
he's like disneyland i want this to be
the happiest place on earth
and he's like i want people to have no
problem no problems with here i want
this to be an escape from your problems
you know you know um in real life and
disney world he's like he created this
thing called epcot which uh i don't know
if you've ever heard of epcot but epcot
is basically
a standard government agency
no it does sound like it though
epcot is like right next to disney world
it's this huge dome looking thing and it
stands for it's an experimental what is
it it's experimental prototype community
of the future
uh something like that of tomorrow and
that's what it stands for um and so what
he did was epcot is basically like
it takes the cutting edge of what the
future looks like and it creates like a
mini simulation of the future so you can
go and see the latest what the what the
future is going to look like in terms of
technology
i've been once when i was a kid yeah
that's kind of amazing and so um and
he's like you know
but all of these projects i'll read you
some of the quotes that i thought was
pretty great for him as like an
entrepreneur he goes um
i want this to be the happiest place on
earth i want compared to kids have fun
together
he goes um
when it came to epcot he's saying uh
where is it
he goes i want this to be a living
blueprint of tomorrow i want this to be
an always evolving thing epcot is never
going to finish because tomorrow will
always be different than today
uh disneyland itself will never be
completed it will go it will go on as
long as there is imagination left in the
world and so since then you know they
built the park for 17 million but
obviously they pour in
like hundreds of millions of dollars
every year to upgrading the parks
changing the the rides and the themes
and all that stuff um in order to kind
of
continuously evolving